[Music]
oh hi I'm Max Keiser this is the Kaiser
report truly electrifying experience
right Stacy well we do have quite an
electrifying experience with this
episode because I have a lot of charts
and they're all from Bank of America's
Michael Hartnett so the headline is
coming from Zero Hedge hitchhikers guide
to the investment universe 20 stunning
market statistics ten years after
central bank's launched the greatest
monetary experiment in history pushing
rates to zero or lower in an attempt to
reflate away an unsustainable debt load
while purchasing 12 trillion dollars in
securities to prop up risk assets we are
back where we started with deflation
once again emerging as the biggest
threat to the world over 10 trillion
dollars in sovereign bonds yielding
below zero percent and after a
disastrous attempt at renormalizing
monetary policy the market is convinced
the Fed will cut rates in the coming
months so with this in this environment
Bank of America's Michael Hartnett has
published its latest hitchhikers guide
to the investment universe and you want
to stimulate the economy do you a
increase wages or be you increase the
price of fine art being sold at
sotheby's that's the question the
Federal Reserve Bank and all central
banks around the world choose be they
want to stimulate the economy by jacking
up the price of fine art and other
collectibles and other assets that are
held by an extraordinarily small portion
of the world's population who haven't
worked in generations there Ron J's they
are the Neel feudal class they are the
kleptocracy but the Fed and the central
banks around the world don't seem to
understand either a how the economy
works or be that if they keep kowtow to
a very small group of Laursen
they're gonna get torched well part of
the issue is that governments themselves
have abdicated any responsibility or
concern for their populations and
they've basically delegated authority
over the economy to the central bank and
the central bank can only implement
monetary policy and monetary policy can
only be executed through their member
banks so that's why all the very wealthy
continue to get very wealthier they the
central bank can't send money to the
ordinary person like the likes of say
Steve King and his policy of
quantitative easing for the people that
has to be done through fiscal policy or
remember when george w bush sent out
checks to every american like six
hundred bucks which I never got mine but
I got mine anyway Reagan was long before
george w bush but so that's why it's
only going to the top in the meantime
the bottom is not it is basically
relative to the top which is taking a
wet taking off and you know rising
further and further away from oh oh i
have a comment
yeah i'm gonna talk about the debt load
that is then piling up because the
bottom is not able to basically
participate in the economy and will come
to your comment after at least one chart
okay cuz i promised people charts 175
trillion dollars current value of global
financial assets which is two times the
size of the global gdp Wall Street is
still too big to fail the total value of
global stocks and bonds outstanding has
jumped by eight fold since 1990 from
twenty three trillion to one hundred and
seventy five trillion today global asset
values are two times the size of the
global economy global asset values fell
in 2018 from 180 trillion to one hundred
and seventy five trillion so everything
kind of starts in 1990 and you see the
debt rise from 23 trillion to 175
trillion mmm what's your comment well
you know they say that the government's
have abdicated their role in managing
they outsource it to the Fed and they
only see things in terms of the
monetarist lens so there's not much they
can do however I would say that they
could raise the cost of committing fraud
right so if you know that the banks are
committing fraud and we know that JP
Morgan and all these other major banks
have paid hundreds of billions of
dollars
Wells Fargo caught defrauding customers
on a wholesale level they can raise the
cost of committing fraud by raising
interest rates so that it's it's not
you're not scented izing fraud it would
also would not incentivize the perpetual
transfusions of this free money to keep
these zombie banks and Sambi
corporations alive so the central banks
do have in their toolbox the ability to
rectify these economic maladies even
within the fact that the governments
have abdicated utterly and no longer see
themselves in that role the central
banks do have ways to rectify the
situation well nevertheless they have
not taken that option made it available
to them so I want to also look at these
charts and it's interesting that they
continue to use 1990 as the beginning
and to today because 1990 is really the
sort of that's the error that the
Generation X entered the work market
that's when we graduated from university
and enter the work market and it's also
kind of when you were a few years into
your working experience so the end of
the baby boomer generation so it's me
it's kind of interesting that that you
know this is all our debt load and the
escalation the exponential increase and
that really started once the baby
boomers were all in the work field they
were already working and they kind of
shape the market around them you could
see them and then Generation X comes in
in 1990 so that's the end of a
generation and the beginning of a new
one and all those behind it I mean this
is the problem we're having now with
this so-called populism whether it's in
Europe or America is that Generation X
Millennials and below have basically
come in at the end of
det well I'm and also as far as the
historically speaking you remember in
1987 you had the plunge Protection Team
come in and save a stock market yeah in
1990 something similar happened in the
bond market the bond market who actually
had a bit of a swoon at that time and
the central banks came in to rescue the
bond market so that's when the beginning
of the plunge Protection Team kind of
spilled over into the bond market and
we've seen the legacy of that now in
2019 2020 where that there is no bond
that the banks won't buy no matter how
much junk it is so again that the value
of financial assets went from 23
trillion in 1990 to 175 trillion today
an Eightfold increase the global debt
outstanding went from 13 trillion in
1990 to a hundred trillion so debt
represents 57 percent of global
financial assets and the value of global
equities outstanding has similarly
surged from 9 trillion in 1990 to 75
trillion today world stock equities
tripled in value
between the global financial crisis lows
in Marsh oh 9 - their most recent peak
of 90 trillion in January of 2018 and
yet like in this sort of period of time
despite all this huge jump these
tripling since just 2009 or the increase
in debt of 9 fold in the past 30 years
like still we're seeing Larry Kudlow you
know the chief economic adviser policy
advisor to the president saying we need
50 basis point cut in the in the Fed
interest rates so like why the panic if
we're booming and everything looks like
boom time the charts look like boot time
and manufacturing is increasing and
construction you know real estate
construction is increasing so why why
why the panic and why do we need even
lower rates yeah what if Bernie Madoff
were allowed to force people to buy into
his fund at gunpoint
if Bernie Madoff had an army and said if
you don't buy into my Ponzi scheme I'm
going to shoot my gun at you even though
the Ponzi scheme was well known to be a
Ponzi scheme remember the SEC had
investigated
made off at least twice before they
finally busted M&E it was a well known
Ponzi scheme invested by well-known
people imagine if Bernie had an army now
apply that to the US dollar the US
dollar is a Ponzi scheme why do people
buy the US dollar because if they don't
the US military is sent in and they're
obliterated whether it's Iraq or Libya
or some other place like this Iran and
so that's what Paul Krugman has said at
the New York Times right he said the US
dollar is worthless it's backed by
violence all fiat is so for example
Europe not America has 11 trillion and
negative yielding debt Denmark is one of
the longest suffering of negative
yielding day they have their own
currency so you know where why it's
still the majority of all transactions
in the globe are u.s. dollar it's the
post-world War two a standard of
economic measurement is the US dollar
and that's why at the moment you have D
dollarization d globalization going on
pretty rapidly and you have the the New
York Times would say this constant
reminder to people around the world
whether it's a CNN that just came out
recently and warned Venezuela to stop
playing games so back to the story about
Bank of America and their charts are
looking at the global economy financial
assets are now 200 percent of global GDP
back in 1990 they were 97 percent so the
percentage of GDP they're twice as big
as the GDP of the global economy now
financial assets back in 1990 when I
first entered the work market it was 97
percent these are you know
psychologically this is a different
world this is a different world we are
looking at today then when Generation X
first entered the work market these are
weights so when you're seeing
Millennials entering the work market or
Generation Z now like this is that what
they're confronting is a global world
saturated with financial assets already
now it's at 200% in 2017 financial
assets we're two hundred and twenty six
percent so two hundred and twenty
percent is the magical number where
everything falls apart and it starts to
crash so we're a little bit below that
we saw
a little bit more before we apparently
crash again but you know these are this
is the dynamics that drive the voter the
the how they perceive the economy what
they look at when they confront the
economy boomer generation entered with
zero debt in the world the you know
probably US debt financial assets were
like fifty percent of the GDP by the
time I entered there was ninety seven
percent and now it's two hundred percent
so at a certain point it's saturated and
they can't absorb any more debt beings
right there is a limit yes and that
limit is historically known to be around
this level before you have a an event a
reversion to the mean and you know what
has reverted to the meme is the dot-com
bubble you were a participant in the
first time something reverted to the
meme or alerted to the mean I mean which
is interesting given this is nineteen
know what years I forget continue so the
past ten years have witnessed the second
great bull market and technology in the
past 25 years in 2018 tech and
e-commerce sectors accounted for 26% of
total market cap now down a little bit
twenty one percent today rivaling prior
sector extreme in the two thousand calm
bubble it was thirty four percent so
dot-com share of the financial markets
is back to close to where it was and the
first calm bubble still quite a ways to
go so whether or not you're looking at
this global economy whether or not like
Larry Kudlow says cut interest rates by
fifty basis points
can we go a little bit further can we
get to those previous extremes and
perhaps past them there does look like a
bit of extreme left around we can push a
little bit more debt into the you know
the economic foie-gras farm and we can
maybe push tech shares up a little bit
higher when how they calculate though
because I don't think they include
FinTech or the banks which have now
become primarily technology companies
and it's not even doing any banking
anymore but anyway we gotta take a break
we're gonna take a short one and then
when we come back we're gonna have so
much fun don't go away stay right there
welcome back to the Kaiser report I'm
Max Keiser time now to go to Craig hemp
ki if TF metals report.com Craig welcome
back max it's always a pleasure nice to
see you and Stacey bowl that's fantastic
now Craig the headlines from the US
manufacturing and construction spending
jumped in March Europe however continues
to contract how long can the u.s. race
ahead of the rest of the world Craig you
know if the first thing that comes to
mind max when you say that is
you might recall a couple of years ago
Janet Yellen famously said we'd never
see another financial crisis in her
lifetime remember that one uh and then
she said I think was just back in
January so wouldn't even a couple of
months ago she said oh well you know
Europe might lead us the whole world
into recession I think she dropped a few
cards on the table there telling you
what's coming yeah and in the US is
clearly slowing too there was some as we
speak some there's an occasional
positive data point in the US but
everything else
retail sales durable goods the
employment report yeah you name it the
first quarter GDP everything points to a
slowdown and as we spoke the three of us
back in January I think this year ends
up looking a lot like the calendar year
2010 where we had come out of the great
financial crisis in 2009 and they had
the Fed had done this one-off policy
there's at least that's what we were
told of quantitative easing it was gonna
be a one-time deal wasn't romana ties in
the debt don't worry about that no no no
no this is just a one-time deal and then
the economy began to slow in the middle
of 2010 and by the end of 2010 we were
doing qe2 and now it you know it's
endless
and I think that's where we're headed
again here people are quickly figuring
out that there will be no rate hikes
this year in fact the bottom mark is
telling you the next one's gonna be a
cut and all of this stuff is becoming
apparent here as we start the second
quarter
you know Gregg it occurred to me that
time has Stood Still is standing still
and what I mean by this is that the US
and the UK in particular are stuck on
stupid we have plain evidence of this
with both brexit and the Russia Gate
hoax breaks it as we've said on this
show for several years it's a logistical
and political impossibility it's like
removing h2 hydrogen from water it's an
it's it's like heart it's like
corralling unicorns it's stupid and
exactly what's happening now is what we
said would happen for years
utter political paralysis and chaos the
Russia gate hoax no matter how much
exonerating information comes out by the
highest courts in America there is still
the doubling down by the deranged lefty
loony Rachel Maddow of the world they
have this collective mutual derangement
syndrome trumped arrangement system set
a symptom and one might try say it's not
syndrome syndrome Thank You Craig and in
the area of econ economics it doesn't
matter what data is published it doesn't
matter what manufacturing data is
published it doesn't matter what the
employment data it doesn't matter no
data it's all nonsense because no matter
what anyone says if the response is
always the same as Larry Kudlow has said
the Fed needs to cut rates by 50 points
if that's always the answer Craig this
is where we're stuck on stupid the world
is dead it died in 2008 we just need to
keep feeding blood to the corpse and
everything will be fine and feed blood
to the brain and Rachel Maddow will
start being a propagandist Tokyo Rose
idiot and Briggs it will happen right
just print more money Craig Wright good
night max you summed it all up right
there my friend that's exactly Larry
Kudlow who I remember from Bear Stearns
he was known as father snow on Wall
Street had a horrible reputation you
know he says we need more drugs
that makes sense for a guy who's got his
reputation Craig well yeah I mentioned
earlier the bond market selling you this
too I mean the way rates have flattened
out and come down just since the last
two weeks after the most recent FOMC I
mean it's telling you what's coming but
you're right I mean max I mean that
we've been in a zombie economy that's
the best way to put it since 2008 9
everything died the Fed the ECB Bank of
Japan I mean you go around the world
there but they've all printed trillions
and trillions of their own currency to
try to real iqua fly their banks and
manage to keep it all in life-support in
the meantime you got all this other
nonsense you know to distract everybody
and keep the political fighting going
that's a whole other story I suppose but
in the meantime as long as the stock
market goes up and and your quarterly
401k statement is higher than it was the
last time then the masses are mollified
and and all of this continues you know I
actually I was just writing for my
subscribers again today and reminding
them that it has now been about a
hundred days ago as the stock market in
the US and around the world was crashing
in December suddenly there's a meeting
of the US working group on financial
markets which you know we'd like to call
the plunge Protection Team and anybody I
mean look go to google and type in
president's working group on financial
markets this isn't like some crazy
conspiracy theory this is a real thing
is crack cocaine
one of the major food groups is heroin
one of the major food groups and I get
healthy by injecting pure smack all day
I don't think so
you know I can have capitalism without
capital and how can you have capital
without a savings rate that anchor
encourages capital formation in other
words if you don't have capital
formation if you don't have interest
rates at least two or three percent to
encourage capital formation and savings
you know you don't have capitalism what
is this what is this economy what do you
call it it's like capitalism it's not
social
is it just a cactus talker see is it a
kleptocracy is it just now is it
feudalism what is it I don't even
understand what it is anymore what do
you call this economy it just looks like
crack ISM I was like kleptocracy for the
you know the root meaning of you know
klepto stealing that's that's what I've
always I you know ever since you go back
to 1913 when the Federal Reserve is
created and you look at how much the
value of the dollar has been devalued
and when you print more dollars and
devalue the dollar you're essentially
stealing from all the people that hold
dollars I mean you I Stasi everybody
listening to us that works whatever we
have left over after we pay our bills is
savings that's an accumulated storage if
you will of all of our efforts and it's
held in dollars and so as the Fed
devalues the dollar they're basically
stealing from you and when they steal
from you they give it to the banks which
then use it to create more dollars and
charge interest on stuff that was
created from nothing kleptocracy is the
the termite that I like to use at least
right well according to economics were
told that supply demand or a factor in
determining prices and yet in the paper
market in the bond market and the
government bond market the supply of
paper has never been higher and yet
prices go up meanwhile in the gold
market demand demand has never been
higher or should it hasn't been high at
this high in 50 years
and of course prices are stagnant so
again supply and demand don't matter you
have in the gold market now you've got
with gold prices are you know sideways
to down and and you know what I mean
isn't even worth you know what can we
say about gold I mean yeah it is
it's money it has no counterparty risk
central banks like Russia China are
buying hundreds of tons of gold central
banks are buying them for the first time
in 50 years
but Chinese public is buying it but I
guess Americans if they own gold that
would give them political agency and
individual sovereignty and then they
might exercise freedom of speech and
there might be a political awakening in
America right so by keeping gold cheap
it's like giving the population of
America stupid pills right max I could I
could send you a link you've probably
seen it wiki links what they call it
wiki cables whatever was that they dug
up and released uh two three years ago
showing electronic communication right
back before the futures marketing gold
was introduced at the December 31st 1974
how they were going to design this so as
to discourage physical gold ownership
the volatility the price suppression all
that kind of stuff would get people to
not want physical gold in the US for the
very reasons that you just mentioned and
then God you think who does actually own
gold you mentioned I mean you go in the
East from Turkey to India to China to
Russia
they're holding physical gold in the
West anybody that does actually own it
on some kind of Alchemy's garbage you
know whether it's a futures contract or
a share of the GLD or some unallocated
account at a you know a Canadian boolean
distributor ID doesn't matter they you
don't actually own gold you and gold
exposure and while the banks can create
as much of that exposure they want in a
kind of a 21st century alchemy that
allows them to manage the price just
like they said they were gonna do with
1974 great on that note the European
Central Bank just stated last week that
member nations need to get approval from
them to manage their national gold
reserves so that's obviously another
attempt to keep gold you know to give
the massive stupid bills now the Fed has
recently suggested that negative rates
are in the cards in the event of another
financial crisis what are they talking
about when this house Oh in the house
prices and construction continues to
boom and manufacturing is increasing we
have
a minute left I'll hold you over for
another segment but can you comment on
that crack well the other sex the other
part of that max that they have to put
in first is that what we call the war on
cash I mean I mean you just follow the
headlines every day and you'll see
little snippets here and there of these
stories that equate holding cash
physical currency hundred-dollar bills
you know with being a drug dealer or you
know a bookie only these illicit
activities require cash so therefore we
should just get rid of it's a lot easier
just to flash a card when you go to
Starbucks anyway if you can eliminate
cash that physical currency then then oh
how easy it is to impose negative
interest rates on people which is just
another form of this wealth confiscation
money confiscation from the banks that's
where we're headed the central banks
have all told you this that everything
is going to be available in the toolbox
as they say the next time the economy's
roll over and and negative interest
rates is one of them which again gets
back to kleptocracy lets us devise all
the different ways we can to steal from
the masses and enrich the few and that's
where this is headed
all right well that's it for this
edition we'll keep you out for other
segments thanks Craig for being on the
Kaiser report all right and that's going
to do it for this edition of the Kaiser
report with me max guys are in Stacy I'd
like to thank our guest Craig hamkke of
TF metals report if you want to catch us
on Twitter it's cars to report until
next time bye yo
[Music]